what is going on reject nation it is
Greg Alva here and it is John Humphrey
over here so we watched the oats to do
volume 1 Braca read from the channel
resurrect neill blomkamp mr. address
today we're going to watch firebase
that's right the second in the volume
one of oats studios new experimental
short I always tell mewho studios it all
right if you're not familiar guys o
Studios is an experimental film
production company spearheaded by Neill
Blomkamp who you know from movies like
district 9 chappie Elysium this is his
new project and they have everything
in-house the full-fledged film studio
they're making these experimental shorts
and they operate on an open source
format which actually allows you if you
go online to steam you can download
elements of the films engage with your
own creativity they're pushing forward
innovating it's pretty cool stuff and
from what we saw yesterday with rakha I
mean these these shorts are pretty
insane
they are pretty insane and today now
this video is up today we're catching up
because not only have subscribers been
asking us to check it out
the zygote the 4th edition is out today
yes and we wanted it to watch all them
so we can be caught up with everything
and as I go when I hear a lot of great
things about I saw some images from it
I'm telling you guys are not feeling
after watching Rakha I'm pretty excited
to get this going John enough talking
let's do this do it the camera cuts
every 12 minutes so we might have to cut
it it's suitable for everyone we saw the
first one I showed my child the first
one one day
my baby the world is not our permanent
home we are looking forward to a home
yet to come Hebrews chapter 13 verse 14
that's from the new test oh my gosh
that's a waste
oh boy a way that is a beating that's
one of the humans are innately
[Music]
boy you Nam been around for a while vibe
nice soft but it should be them it looks
like actual footage from it might be I
mean there's a lot of stock footage
[Music]
whoa
Oh oh man not restrictive no friendly
for sure
Oh whoo where's some gloves man they all
got
[Music]
whoa
is definitely real food fascinating
[Music]
that's a lot of a lot of dead people
yeah
[Music]
the way
[Music]
Wow stockbridge effect may look even
more real that
[Music]
damn government covering all this up
it's pretty horrifying about into some
historical third screwed now it just
feels like what is just daughter could
be better damn happy now more with ugly
ugly yeah
and one design so I want to war the
spear and then never to me loom love
they just walking on the narrow and
Christopher Walken doing that your
alternative time
[Music]
that's how you get it done whoa whoa
[Music]
[Music]
she started running yeah
gingka bomber Central Intelligence
Agency the guy you've been communicating
with it's not the cars so you can
observation group far from your friend
sergeant Hines you want it off your unit
agenda turning when I do port marshals
that's not a real drawn to it you have
to kill it yeah too late no ever God did
they three days ago
get some men up here to clean this up
come on the town I have something to
show you
it's like mythology theory
Oh movie huh yeah
I heard near wall catwalk all this money
yeah please a surviving room
yeah he's brixton he's an alien looks
you cool just eclectic Jase doc told me
my pills hits and lots of things for us
you got our asses whooped by VC ambush
we wait for reinforcements when the
soldiers came they were uh they were
monsters in the statement man they
wouldn't die no but human said we
retreated to firebase Turia's always try
to you but tarios gone
just [ __ ] off that's gonna cold near
strike
Villa de tomate liar we burn everything
[Music]
no pain except for the Napalm this you
can do something I'll never be able to
explain I was neither certainly sent
look I'm not here to connect the dots
for you the events of Tarheel are
classified
I got me missing and I trust man I know
man I should love it and the same things
happens in this he can't explain I'm
voices and they saw the devil
piffle yes I watch your Mendez kill the
devil I think the CIA better start to
explain what the [ __ ] is going on here
you can have a mutiny on your hands damn
government
[Music]
they should be like a horror movie
yeah this puts foreboding like a horror
war movie please state your name bracket
corporal Richard Rackham sir all right
please are count the events at firebase
Tar Heel how did you get burned
what happened Wow
they started weird something a little
bank just excited
well came down for us to get some into
[Music]
camera guy since it cuts every 12
minutes
[Music]
camera guys mayor garrison with us
[Music]
when fire-based article corporal
[Music]
whoa
[Music]
[Music]
Wow I always be that it's like
accumulating flesh
[Music]
[Music]
this guy
Wow he's looking right at me not I felt
anything like that so one minute I'm in
a jungle looking at that
see the next time in South Carolina back
of the day we opened up sauce I don't
mean like a dream or not I mean I was in
America and they were all destroy
everyone repair
[Music]
this or scenarios
[Music]
Oh being slain a tall right-hander and
the story they reporting that bulges
boarding
right yes
[Music]
did I have an eternal sin airbase or
just select chill so they all did travel
safe they did happen
if
because in
threatening the boys they pulled me on
the ditch I'm still on fire
here yeah here in the jungle
[Music]
Wow I was like Sheree I'm on fire but
they pulled me out of South Carolina in
Vietnam
[Music]
like my buddies were on the resume
[Music]
body-snatcher isn't dead like ghosts
nice size like spiders you think
I also NASA hero Oh No Oh Danny Matteson
senior hey guys Ted Thank You Saul you
bragging who's that soldier is a good
actor cabrakan be flown back to the
States
enrolled at MK search and his name will
be stricken off the rolls here
officially bmia along with the 318 other
Americans want the target as of this
moment I have a start he'll never exist
UNCA get some rest we head out in a few
hours
try
[Music]
please don't start peeling your flesh
off some decks were wrong like cosmic
Leary's Oh
that's not easy
a lot of its condiments
really alive tell me
beers man always married they're gonna
duds and I know that right I'm not sure
you care if these soldiers live or die
you don't even care if you live or die
maybe that's how it works
who are you what are you becoming these
details are slipping away from you
aren't they I can help are you what are
you becoming
have dreams
more like visions trying to tell me
something to understand saying just nice
[Music]
I spoke to soldiers in your previous
unit I've heard all the accounts about
you I didn't meant to die I just
protected by a divine hand
well objects will put in their path to
Sheol you put there to attack to exactly
the right moment to denote a piece of
shrapnel sums of it life itself the
video coming the universe keeping you
alive
saving you as though it has a plan for
you in the river god that man you're
compelled to hunt he is an error of a
steak playing sinful life once ain't God
what is he
a simple villager
there is no connection the Viacom
get a wife
he had children
[Music]
whoa
oh he was pushed by grief
to the point where the very fabric
toured around him I'm in their local
villagers who knew a man they began
calling him the river god
they wandered the mekong leaving wake of
destruction I didn't even think he knows
he's doing these things these horrors
manifesting reality through his
subconscious thoughts changing matter
inside the dead how crazy animating them
his visions of his own hell eventually
we wandered into an NVA base begging for
help should be the last time I cut
through reaction by that point is
slashed shut entirely the dog
Wow
[Music]
invisibility curtain Russia
oh and just wow as a god
talking your mind is set free we will
set the jungle and fire burn everything
until flaming gels ladders across it
lighting him up for us to track we will
find him
this is the electromagnetic coil gun
firing projectiles in about 120 of his
people a long cap weapons yeah future
tagging real to tap it creates an
atmosphere positives negative polarity
everything about this is designed to
keep reality unbroken so you can
function your Walter deserves protection
from the very demonstate I'm
you call it a relativity castle it
amplifies the gift you already have
amplifies we give you already
[Music]
well or not God that she may be immersed
and whooping his schemes
the devil
Oh Oh
why we want more yeah
you know I like the hospital review when
the credits are done
but I will say man that was that was
awesome I like them now in the first one
hell yeah well yeah you know cuz this is
going to a period piece you know yeah so
mixing into more like almost fantasy
element yeah and I like those touches
from Neil Blomkamp when he does that was
film you blend sci-fi and fantasy
together oftentimes well yeah even
though he systematically but this seems
like a very appearance here yeah like
theoretical types on a oh yeah like you
got the cool tech in the cool designs
and everything and like you know it's
captured amazingly adult so yeah it's
breaching it out is that that whole
thing about like just this guy's world
broke apart very special manifest that's
in a thoughtful moment that he
transformed play I love I love those
kind of supernatural type of characters
who manifest a demeaning grief well that
almost sounds like a story that you know
you might have especially in that time
it sounds almost like a like a horse or
like a ghost story I'm kind of you know
spooky out in the jungle
and oh man you know I I don't oftentimes
like we get requests to do like long ass
videos to check out and honestly John
and I we don't John and I we don't
really look forward to sitting in front
of a camera and watch it son like this
we prefer to just like sit on our couch
and watch it especially lately it is
yeah but I got a saying that went by so
fast
oh yeah that was incredibly gripping and
entertained totally or I
I wasn't even you hear about the amount
of time I was because I don't know if I
watch it we showed yeah this river god
it makes me wonder how they're building
all this because the first one ends on a
note too with a mirin nosh and Sigourney
Weaver's character they're going to go
out on a very specific mission that big
place in 2020 and then this takes place
during the Vietnam War
yeah and its ends in a similar fashion
oh we gotta go take down the enemy and
the enemy the aliens look different yeah
then the other ones so I'm wondering is
like by the time we get to a last
installment is it all going to come
together yeah I'm hoping they do that
just keep anything on these cool whippet
here's of they're going to go take down
the a lien enemy I obviously I don't
know what their brainstorm and what
their idea is from the inside you know
what all this might be leading to but I
wonder if also you know over the course
of volumes you know we'll see a
different structural thing take place
hopefully it'll seem at least pretty
different as of now well I think that
you know like we said on our first one
for rakha that it takes it's really
building up environment mood tone and
while they establish all that there and
this takes place in different era so I
thought we're gonna have to do a lot of
reestablishing that I was more invested
in the characters in this one probably
because I I just saw I've been watching
the documentary the 60s from CNN and
they just covered the Vietnam War and it
was the first time in my life where I've
ever heard about you know where my whole
life it was the first time really struck
me I remember you came through the door
Ellen I do I should the sixties
documentaries Vietnam War
and what we do that no what does happen
yeah was it fiction I was like mad about
it happening as if it just happened
recently yeah and I didn't know what
firebase was about it took place during
this time I really appreciated that you
know my closest connection to
understanding with being a word like is
watching films like Apocalypse Now or
platoon or come sky long Skull Island
which I want to touch on a second
because I loved that it really captured
that type of tone and style it has this
historical fiction with its apocalypse
now traumatic we shouldn't be here type
of territory yeah and yeah like like
this is a slog for all and yet you know
and the mixture of stock footage doing
the stock footage effects was really
good here because it made it look that
much more real when they were doing the
crazy sci-fi stuff going on it did make
me think halfway through like this is
what Kong Skull Island kind of wanted to
be yeah we were to take the Vietnam War
but infuse it with these other elements
your honor and then it kind of just
can't all the Vietnam War elements and
it turned into comics go island for most
of the film gear I know this is just a
short film but it kept that Vietnam War
flare of a soldier traumatized soldier
being witness to all these things and
having to be involved in the violence
with the whole alien aspect as well
which I really appreciated when I was
watching this oh yeah one even things
like that that whole interlude where
they jump to Charleston and it's like
you know the the Russian Russian ships
trains Russian ship is laying islets of
that actor that like I was that guy man
he was great yeah I'm not in familiar
with the cast in this one but yes
especially the guy who was the the
corporal like that guy was so natural a
monologue was amazing and I come to
appreciate about you know Neill Blomkamp
joints in general but it's holding up
here you know like we all we all kind of
got to when he brought sharlto copley
like big onto the scene because we're
like well I got a terrific actor and it
seems like he just knows a lot of pretty
terrific yeah anybody don't like films
like Liam or chappie I'm like the acting
so really damn good because this really
was Apocalypse Now the main character
reminding me of Martin
and how Martin Sheen is you know he's
traumatized war vet and the brain and
men on a very specific mission at the
tape-recorded and all that stuff and the
interview is going on he's getting to
listen in on which is putting him on
this very specific mission but I love
that from the first one and then this
one they're building a whole mythology
as well yeah this is a real world
exploration I like the anthology style
I'm hoping it leaves you cinematic
universe they don't see you yeah it does
feel like it's building that because
honestly I be kind of bummed if it did
it this all didn't eventually come back
and they conclude some of this yeah they
are calling this volume once maybe their
volume wanting all the all these
specific storylines and them are all
they're all going to finally wrap up
eventually when they said in their in
their sort of mission statement it's
their hope that at least some of these
could maybe become feature films
eventually that would be really cool
because this one I'm really daunting
I just love historical fiction in
general I'm not too familiar with
stories I really do historical fiction
during the Vietnam War era the infusion
here was great one thing we haven't
touched on designs in here oh yeah not a
flesh peeling that was going on here was
crazy in any Neil Blomkamp movie you
watch you know I'm pretty well firm has
unique design work there's a look you
know like at least it's consistent
there's certain earmarks of is most
different yeah definitely because then
in you know going back in time so far II
I know seems like it's kind of flexing a
different side of that sci-fi horror but
yeah this one is very sci-fi war horror
yeah and and you know beyond just the
technology designs like yeah the the
designs of the gore and the
manifestation of the physical impact of
this is that was one of the most
mind-blowing things about this was like
the effects like especially when they're
peeling off body parts and stuff and
it's like it's really gross but it's
also like Christmas tree you can help
that and then the creature do any this a
skeleton and then it's assembling itself
from flesh and then it has this perfect
design by the end that nuts I don't know
how they did that but that looked
amazing incredible no I mean there are
certain effects that
and more seamlessly than others and
especially when you have you know the
the older look with bigger effects you
know sometimes you can tell that this
especially when the the river god that
creature comes together like that looked
like it was there yeah you know and like
there it seems like the experiments that
are doing are really breaking some
ground in terms of effects and the river
god element the character does have that
more of the fantasy element like that by
the time it's fully assembled it did
kind of look I don't know like a lord of
the Rings type of character or a sour on
what a character when he's fighting it
looks like kind of a mythical Ward
really make sense what it called the
river god and then even was like the
humans being embodied it didn't have
this like zombie invasion of the body
snatchers type of vibe that weary
and they you know great great body
language acting yeah I feel like though
what connective tissue is the jungle
music and having this like jungle war
territory by Bataan but you know I mean
there's there's a good a through line of
slum enos you know and whatever the
circumstances are you know we're we're
never in a very nice place for very cool
yeah in a lot of these that I think we
also kind of got what we wanted coming
off of Rekha into this one you know
we're getting a more focused uh takes
its time or because because the Iraq of
the wreck is a lot of detail and
explanation and while hopping around
with small character moments this one
right yeah I'll really took its time and
pacing a lot more it isn't like a few
minutes longer and the dialogue you know
because of that flows differently like
there's more writing and yeah which is
nice and there's you know more character
which I know we expressed a wish for
getting to know some character you get a
neo Blomkamp touches a special guns the
special suit but this really is a
different side because when you see rock
I you're like this is super vintage
Blomkamp yeah when you watch this one
you're like I would guess this is a
Neill Blomkamp but I would've definitely
hired but I wouldn't be entirely sure if
it was Neill Blomkamp it's funny it's
trouble summons video game movies have
become like there is a you can feel the
video game and I can feel that this guy
likes game yeah oh yeah you know library
bear in a good way and I feel like this
is some of the best translation of
what's cool about games too
yeah cinema you just just throughout his
working and they didn't comes out more
in this stuff you know because I have an
idea he should do a halo movie that
might work produced by Peter Jackson or
Stevensville or skewed filler you never
know never known another price they've
never tried you I gotta give it to them
every time like some kind of big
property it seems like it's about to
come together and does it we get
something even cooler yeah yeah yeah now
we got oh it's like and and yeah this is
you know he's got a very distinct style
and when I again appreciate about what
this adds to his style what both of
these shorts have added in in their own
way is like you said the horror elements
the foreboding and like they have been
gripping yeah you know I've been gripped
by both of these genuinely in a way that
a lot of big blockbuster movies I rely
on this yeah I'm like flew by yeah yeah
yeah this is exciting to me well we're
gonna watch the third one now which I
hear is three times the amount length
yeah next one so it's really only four
minutes long yeah but then I think Zygo
the four of the lenses came out is the
actual like another from lengthy one I'm
looking forward to it I'm actually I'm
really enjoying these new blog one if
you go on to if you go on Steam and you
watch or I think they're on YouTube to
some of the like the weird infomercials
- mm-hmm what really some of them on
YouTube completely clean ones yeah yeah
a completely different style tone look
everything and I I watched one of them
this morning
all the distraint well I think that's in
a good way I think it's a great idea
because you know one thing that I felt
people didn't understand about chappie
and then we felt people doing our
sandwich Appy and then when we heard
Neill Blomkamp talk about it recently it
was like a crossing of different types
of genre and style that people didn't
quite catch on - yeah and I feel like
here he just gets to really do that in
short film for me yeah yeah he's good at
Randy and his crew you know everybody
all the elements come together
I always feel a lot when I'm watching
that movie they always make me feel a
certain way both in my head and just you
know getting caught up in it moving and
stuff they're always very evocative yeah
I've never seen a bland Neill Blomkamp
anything well you guys I highly suggest
if this you've only watched our react
watch the video from there I highly
suggest pulling this up on your TV or a
computer and why the whole thing in the
fullscreen format because man that was
something special and I can't wait for
the rest if you're into what they're
doing without studios and you want to
contribute and get involved if you go on
steam you can I think it's like five
bucks you can download it really for
$99.99 for each of these shorts at least
they have these packages that have like
high quality file versions of of each
short they have the daily as they have
the sound stems they have the concept
are the 3d models so you know you can
take a look at all that which is awesome
but you know if you're so inclined you
can actually make stuff out of it to
subscribe to out Studios channel on
YouTube and subscribe to the rail
rejects click that notification though
he is that John Humphrey on Twitter and
Instagram social media manager Blum
house follow me at the Greg Alva we have
an Instagram apparently now that John
started up I did we haven't read it
patreon so go check out our patreon for
exclusive perks and rewards mal types